when you look back what is your greatest
to compensate all right
in terms of writing yeah I think in
terms of being on it I'd have to say
because Seth Meyers wrote this sketch
and then a man I just pitched jokes in
addition to it but I'd have to say want
some of those Sarah Palin things were
probably the biggest oh yeah thing that
was are a part of it was crazy right
it was crazy whole first notice that you
kind of resembled Sarah Palin who told
Lauren because you had to come back to
Saturday Night Live yeah I was at 30
rock and don't won't even notice that I
had left but someone figured out you
look like Sarah Palin Lauren it wasn't
like he knew something was up because he
came downstairs and his doorman was like
what a gift Oh Tina Fey what a gift so
the doorman told Lauren Dorman's well he
was like oh well she doesn't work at the
show anymore he's like we got our and
then he walked out of the building
walked down the street and ran into
Robert DeNiro
yes who said what a gift oh you how much
do they look like
Lorne heard Robert De Niro say that with
everybody yeah yeah and so like within
five minutes region he's like I think we
have to contact think about this yeah we
have to consider when he calls you you
look like Sarah Palin do you say these
oh [ __ ] do I even want to go back to
Saturday Night Live it's because was
this unspoken thing where I was walking
around 30 rock being like I don't know
should I even do it but it was like by
the way like no one had actually asked
me to do really arrogant like no one
asked me to do it I mean Lauren hadn't
even said to you we talked about the
joke of people saying because I would
still talk to him all the time because
the 30 rock of people saying you look
like her but no one was saying like it
mates it's like they always thought I
think SNL is like the these they're like
the king of well let me put it in a
little bit like they never say like they
never say like come down here do this so
he's like if you want to come by Friday
night we'll have a sketch and we can
order Chinese what it's always like vary
the ease you into what is this I don't
get rejected and you and there's no
pressure there's no space for you to say
no so then they say to you hey you look
like Sarah Palin yeah
now do you start working on an
impression of her I try to you know I I
think once we sort of said like come by
and we'll see it and I was sort of like
I don't work there anymore I don't do
impressions I think I started maybe
looking to see
if there was anything to be had because
I watched other people do because he do
a really good impression I think I used
but she does like I said she has like a
sling blade voice like she has a voice
anyone can do it like it's not like I
don't think or but wait a second you say
that she has a distinctive funny way of
talking
well Alaska and Russia are only
separated by a narrow maritime border
you've got Alaska here that you don't go
to like some coach to help you figure
out the dialect my friend Paula she her
grandma was from Minnesota or something
and we sort of just patterned it off
politic oh you should be like Oh Paula
sleep and you can't so we just like kind
of worked off that oh so that's what you
do yeah cuz you just take a Minnesota
and I take us some kind of you know bad
accent and just try and it's try yeah
that's so great you could slip into it
easily Kenny I actually haven't tried in
in years so I would be afraid to I would
go see you do it's one woman Sarah Palin
it's an hour do it for six months run I
would go see that